[Musique]
c'est une ambiance studieuse une
ambiance de travail flagrante y règne
lorsque l'on pénètre dans l'enceinte du
chanvre et touraine handball un groupe
pro quatorze joueurs sous contrat très
concernés
malgré une année tronquée s'adapte au
mieux on essaie de garder les intensités
à l'entraînement éviter les blessures
surtout parce que rester deux semaines
sans jouer au point des matchs et pas
forcément évident pour le corps on s'en
rend pas compte mais c'est quand même
assez dangereux les chambraisienne reste
concentré sur le projet de jeu présenté
en début de saison est parfaitement
assimilé cambrai c'est quand même connu
de base pour être un club un petit peu
dans la défense on a toujours voulu
avoir une grosse défense
on a des super gardien derrière donc
pour l'instant ça marche plutôt bien et
on a une volonté de courir et des
concours bien que la passe la balle
circule bien on trouve des solutions
maintenant là sur les derniers matches
mais justement c'est là que le bât
blesse c'est qu'on a pas bien pousser la
balle on a perdu beaucoup de ballons ce
qui n'est pas dans nos habitudes
analyse vidéo combinaison énergie
positive
le coach ne lésine pas sur les détails
pour maintenir le groupe éveillé ce qui
m'ennuie dans cette non ce match là
c'est qu'il ya deux moments où quand on
est à + 5 dans les deux mi-temps on
descend bas on fait des erreurs
ayrault et on paye cash
le ct hb et pourtant à l'heure au rendez
vous de ses objectifs à mi parcours
même s'il ya des matches en retard à
jouer chambrée temps au tableau derrière
metz et brest les deux grosses
cylindrées
j'ai la chance d'avoir un groupe super
ça avec des lunettes qui sont vraiment
droite qui vont qui bosse fort fort
poids on arrivé là
maintenant je pense que on peut se baser
sur des joueurs surtout qu'on une
expérience du très haut niveau linda
pradel la capitaine on est l'exemple
parfait
après il ya eu au ghana stojkovic aussi
qu'il vient de faire le championnat
d'europe donc on peut se baser aussi sur
ces choses là qui nous permettent de
mettre une certaine exigence au niveau
du groupe
six ans après son accession parmi
l'élite le chb n'a jamais eu autant
d'ambitions en visant l'europe
et si certaines joueuses de l'effectif
pouvait s'en détourner la direction du
club est toujours là pour marteler les
objectifs je pense doivent être
conscients là il est important qu'on se
fasse une ou deux séances qui soit
vraiment à la hauteur de la qualité
qu'on attend et qu'on soit prête pour le
combat et le défi qu'il y aura mercredi
soir c'est sûr et pour s'appuyer sur son
développement
le club peut désormais compter sur une
salle a grandi et relooké elle permettra
d'accueillir jusqu'à 1200 spectateurs
potentiels des soirs de match un
argument de plus pour trouver toute sa
place sur l'échiquier sportif
tourangeaux ont la vision d'une club je
veux vraiment que ça devienne une
institution en touraine du sport au
féminin du sport de haut niveau du
handball aussi parce que je pense que ça
aussi de belles vertus et
et en tout cas on va on va s'appliquer
là dessus on veut s'intégrer
bien sûr par le sport bien sûr par le
haut niveau bien sûr par l'europe mais
aussi par nos valeurs club tourangeau
est fier d'être à haut niveau et d'être
présenté la tourette et chambre et on va
créer unis et en conquête
il faudra le rester pour valider les
objectifs et s'asseoir durablement dans
l'élite
y'aura pas le femina
[Musique]